[Music]
production design is having to create
worlds like every little bit of it
from the details to the general
principle of the universe hello my name
is Leroy new I'm from the Philippines
and I'm a practicing artist and I also
do production design
[Laughter]
[Music]
I've always been interested in these
fantasy worlds growing up in the south
of the Philippines where I'm from we had
this whole mythology of Catholicism kind
of just constantly being presented to us
and at the same time I was fascinated
with local superstition which you know
my grandmother would originally tell me
about you know local monsters and
spirits
[Music]
I wanted to kind of create my own
mythology by overlapping all these
different influences from religion to
pop culture to all the frustrations of
living in a third-world country it's
very common in the urban landscape for
you know Filipinos to reuse a lot of
materials and transform them into like
handcrafted sculptural pieces I mean we
were not trained to throw away stuff
just like that I love experimenting with
what the world already has to offer
instead of like making something from
scratch
so me and my collaborators have always
you know problematized avenues of
presenting art and that led me to
realize that the inanimate objects that
I started doing as a trained sculptor
were not enough anymore so they had to
be like lived in the objects should be
war and not just like looked at you know
they needed to be performed in
[Music]
[Music]
artists particularly are great examples
of those people who thrive on on this
chaos you know like we make something
out of it
it's kind of coping mechanism for us at
the same time exposing the systems that
determine our lives
[Music]
you